yeah welcome to this video yes I know it
looks at different and it's only a test
video this is also why I'm just playing
a three-minute game I'm experimenting a
bit here with software check and
different setups and this is actually
channeling that I'm trying here with the
xsplit software which is used to
broadcast your live streams to twitch
but you can also record videos there and
I tried something new so I'd like to
have some feedback how do you like this
setup it is a possible idea to use this
setup for future blitz games so it's um
there are some changes obviously I've
got a webcam now on the right hand side
I changed something about the way the
move list is presented so there is some
things gone from the set up the clocks
are a little bit bigger that's maybe a
matter of taste and what it also has
this when I'm going to analyze the game
afterwards we will have an engine view
this has been requested a number of
times and with exploit I can actually
alter the screen this state in a way
that I can yeah I can give a view on the
webcam on the content Ellis's yeah and
the webcam so if I do this as a standard
setup for my for my blitz videos yeah um
then you will always have a picture of
me on it yeah it's obviously matter of
taste yeah do you like to see me over
the time or not yeah I'd like to have
feedback on that what about this setup
do you like it do you not like it what
do you like about it what what's bad
yeah so as much feedback as possible
yeah this game here I'm playing this
game mostly to have some action on the
board so that you can somehow see is
this a statuary video is this
yeah is this fine whatever um what what
kind of game is that actually I'm having
a good position here right can take only
five and have a really nice position
this is a three minute game this is a
different rating pool which I normally
don't play simply because it's um a
little bit too quick to do decent
commentary with and this is why I prefer
five minute and also how reason why my
rating is so low I simply don't play
them so Knight takes e5 for yeah I don't
really want Luke takes the one that's
not so nice look at you one King you
what I mean yeah but okay I have to play
a bit quicker here this is three minute
oh he's not taking on d1 that's nice of
him and what now I guess bird to eat who
simply for Luke t1 check that's just a
nice position for white he's got
weaknesses all over the place
he father's a weak pawn d5 is the weak
Square and so on it goes on and on
basically so what now and maybe here
double-checking and no Knight f3 to look
at the weekly five pawn
he's got Knights 6m to cover cover stuff
but time warning it's still quite quite
nice for me Bishop d3 if for would be
nice okay so he tried to play against
that hmm I can still take the habit it's
not such a great idea maybe do some
small improving efore Bishop g7 is
winning for wide so I have some leeway
here let's try to get something to eat
for
[Music]
I see wriggling out of that yeah okay at
the time mm-hmm the time the time the
time
[Music]
going over to g3 and covering f2 at
least this guy is not playing super
quickly that's good so I don't get into
until you show you know is spending for
some time okay so I'd love to get 90 to
win but Shaq always this rook trade
would be nice so he does that and I know
I'm better again Bishop f3 and so on 92
924 and so on and widest better check
[Music]
yeah I have to have to be quick okay I
might be better but it's not like I'm
gonna be winning not winning at all
actually probably it is really just the
draw
check check check check white forfeits
I'm home feed on time and what a shame
yeah yeah well three minutes is really
not the time control to do commentary
fun you can do that but it's not it's
not what I'm used to but it was about
the technical side of things so did you
enjoy this system it's just something to
to do for the regular daily blitz games
one thing I wanted to show you is that I
can whoops yeah I can
actually get the engine on yeah which is
not very exciting for the final position
it is just a made in a couple of moves
but I can I can jump to any position and
I can actually show you now what stock
fishes is giving and yeah I was normally
quoting the the stock fish lines but
yeah I can now just fodder for the
analysis if we quickly click through
things here jump to a certain point you
can always get the the stock fish
analysis and why am I not jumping there
it's a bit strange check yeah somewhere
somewhere around the game you can always
have the the evaluation on the screen
yeah I can switch it on and off and like
off and on off and on really nice so on
it's not like I want to use the engine
all the time I want to get some idea of
my own and switch it on you very like
and then I can also show you the
evaluation so here this it is off again
yeah so please give me some feedback how
you like this layout is this something
that I should do for the daily blitz
games I'm not talking about live streams
where I definitely will use the layout
but it's about the daily blitz videos
this is something that I should use for
those or not yeah well thanks for
watching this and I welcome your
feedback just write what you think
thanks for watching